concerning your research for you this
morning revealing how the pandemic is
affecting our blood pressure a recent
study found that average blood pressure
levels rose significantly from april
through december of 2020 that's compared
to 2019 no pandemic then the study
looked at nearly 500 000 adults in the
u.s and there was also more of an
increase among women than men also in
older adults the cdc says high blood
pressure increases the risk of heart
disease and stroke two leading causes of
death here in the united states our
senior medical correspondent dr taran
rula is also a cardiologist at northwell
health and she joins us now uh dr narula
why the increase in blood pressure
what's a simple explanation here well
simply we know that so much of your risk
of developing high blood pressure or
having your blood pressure worsen is
based on lifestyle factors and you can
imagine all of our lifestyle has changed
in the last almost two years and so
while the researchers didn't point to
any definitive reasons we can all
surmise that there probably were changes
in how we were eating so
possibly more salt consumption more
alcohol consumption maybe people were
more sedentary less active may have
gained some weight sleep patterns
changed and then a lot of people missed
their appointments with their doctors
or if they did have visits they were
televisions where their blood pressure
wasn't being potentially measured in the
office what concerns you most about it
because a lot of times you don't even
know your blood pressure is going up
it's not something that you really feel
and a lot of my patients say why do i
have to take medication i feel fine and
that's really the concern
one of your patients yes one of my
patients gail
but no the the concern is that blood
pressure you know every heartbeat your
blood vessels are seeing this very high
pressure and it's damaging to the
vessels all over the body and so what it
does is it increases your risk for
future complications things like heart
attack and stroke and heart failure and
then things that a lot of people don't
think about like vision changes sexual
dysfunction and kidney problems and you
know as you mentioned gail lots of times
it can be silent that's why we call it
the silent killer you may not have
symptoms sexual dysfunction
is tied to blood pressure it can be yes
yes so even more reason to get a check
yes blood flow matters so is that one of
the warning signs that there might be
people are listening a little bit closer
what did you say
so uh what are some of those warning
signs right so a lot of people think you
know oh severe headaches or nosebleeds
and yes sometimes that can be a sign or
shortness of breath or chest pain but a
lot of times there are no signs and
that's why it's really important to
start having your blood pressure being
checked at the age of 20. that's really
what the american heart association
recommends right that's really early and
to have it screened annually if it's
normal and possibly you know more often
if it's not normal and you know i think
one important thing is to know your
numbers and a lot of people get told oh
your blood pressure's fine but actually
it's not fine and when they come to see
me i say well it's pretty high actually
and so a normal number is less than 120
and less than 80. okay anything less
yeah so 120 to 130 is already elevated
for the top number
yeah and high blood pressure over 130
over 80. any holiday recommendations for
managing one's blood pressure right so
make sure you bring your medications
make sure that you try to stay as active
as possible so even if you're on
vacation try to look at how much salt
you're consuming avoid adding salt and
really read those labels if you can if
you're perfect holiday dinners that's
right and alcohol consumption goes up
this time of year exactly so something
else we tend to and then stress right a
lot of people are under more stress when
they're around certain family members
yeah and you're not trying to be a
buzzkill you're just trying to keep us
happy and healthy that's right very
important information here enjoy your
holidays but also be mindful that it's
not just a vacation from your health
during this time you got to pay
attention thank you so much know your
numbers yes great advice